welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and the Empire Strikes Back the
follow-up to George Lucas's Star Wars
has gained a legacy as a darker richer
chapter from a bygone era when
melodramatic twists and sequels that
revised their predecessors were
appreciated if Star Wars was the
favorite film of every doe-eyed eighties
kid Empire was a favorite of every
eighties moody older brother to really
understand Empire little brother one
must first understand the wampa after
re-watching the first Star Wars let us
now break down the finer details and
Empire to explain how despite reviews at
the time so mixed that George Lucas
apologized for it
this film tops so many best of lists
even though it came out in 1980 I feel
like I gotta say it for this movie
spoiler warning for the movie that
defined everything about spoiler culture
okay here we go the opening crawl begins
with but survived this blew everyone's
minds in 1980 because three years
earlier the first Star Wars had no
episode number at the top of the crawl
in 1981 the first Star Wars was
re-released in theaters and Lucas added
Episode four a new hope to the top of
that crawl Lucas did this after working
with Empire's original screenwriter
science fiction writer Leigh Brackett
whose writings and discussions with
Lucas eventually led to him billing in a
detailed backstory for Darth Vader's
past as Anakin Skywalker his
relationship with obi-wan in the fall of
the Jedi which of course would later
lead to the prequels so as Lucas revised
the script with Larry Kasdan he decided
the story that we've seen so far is an
matthias rests all part of a deeper
history than we realized in this opening
sentence and Empire scroll is a firm
declaration that this next chapter will
not be the fantasy caper like the first
it's a darker moodier examination of the
villain who only got 12 minutes of
screen time in the first Star Wars Darth
Vader the most active and consequential
character in this installment the
opening planets shows how this story
will be an elemental inverse of its
predecessor switching from the scorching
deserts of Tatooine to the frozen
Tundras of Hoth shot on the glaciers of
Norway and rather than opening with the
lovable droids r2d2 and c3po this time
we open on a droid who would probably go
to droid hell if there is one the evil
imperial Luke Skywalker rides a tauntaun
a two legged mount inspired by the
creature ridden by the Necron 99 from
the 1977 animated film Wizards originaly
tontons were conceived of as lizards but
were redesigned to approximate bighorn
sheep though still having some reptilian
qualities Lucas gets blindsided by a
based on the Yeti a folklore and
real-life early versions of the wampa
established them with supernatural
powers capable of swimming through the
hoff snow like a fish with some others
captured inside the rebel base y scene
deleted from the evac sequence would
have shown a room in the base where
captured wampa are kept as seen in a
brief shot in the theatrical trailer
Threepio would have ripped off the
danger sign from the door tricking some
strong tripperz into going in there now
it was believed that this wampa attack
was written to explain the scars on mark
Hamill's face from a car accident 1977
but really Hamill scars had mostly
healed by the time Empire started
production his scars later on his face
were created by makeup another
misconception is the wampa itself the
one who attacks Luke is not the one in
the cave there are male and female wampa
and actually the one that we see in the
cave in the wider angle eating was not
in the original version of the film it
was added in a 97 special edition played
by ILM staffer Harold weaned on a cave
set that was built with a roof only four
and a half feet tall to make him seem
like he's 9 or 10 feet tall the original
the actual wood cut just showed the
whompin close-up it looked a bit campy
Luke hangs upside down here he actually
finds himself upside down
three times this movie in the cave and
act 1 on Dagobah and act 2 and hanging
from Cloud City and act 3 each time he's
forced to use the Force to get out of it
and it reflects the upturn to
perspective Luke leaves this movie with
along with like the wampa here one limb
viewer while all this is going on han
Solo Chewbacca and Leia are back on the
rebel base han is fearing the bounty on
his head and he wants to bounce decided
to stay in 1983 there was a radio drama
called rebel mission to Ord Mantell in
which Luke and Hans seek a new base but
really just to throw off the Empire
sense han we need you
George Lucas Commission director Irvin
Kershner to direct this film and one of
Kirchner's greatest contributions to the
Star Wars series was his focus on the
human drama between Han Leia and the
other characters Star Wars was extremely
plot driven basically a beat for beat
adaptation of Joseph Campbell's monomyth
a story of King Arthur set in space well
again everywhere is space but in a
galaxy far far away Empire by comparison
it's not really that plot dependent it's
more of a study of character in
relationship dynamics well the plot
often treads water on Dagobah or clunks
around on the Falcon our focus is pulled
instead to the fiery passion between Han
and Leia the trusting friendship between
Luke and Han the creepy paternalistic
Drive of Darth Vader when the rebels
close the doors on han and Luke Chewie
roars and agony you feel his pain and
later when Luke suits up and says bye -
Han he almost says something instead he
just smiles at his friend the last time
they'll see each other before Han gets
frozen a moment that feels so tragic
because in the first act han saves Luke
from getting frozen but Luke is not able
to save Han from getting frozen sea
Kirchner turns the character archetypes
from the first film into living
breathing feeling humans without this
addition the Star Wars franchise would
not inspire the deep emotional
connection among fans that leads us to
cosplay and decades later tear up at
things like Chewie among the rebels
major brand erlan is actually a cameo by
John Ratzenberger cheers and all the
Pixar movies later there will be another
cameo the rebel crossing with the
notepad is artist Ralph McQuarrie who
conceived so much of the look of the
original trilogy in his artwork - still
being used in the new films Han rescues
Luke by cutting open his Taunton and
covering Luke in its entrails when
Leonardo DiCaprio did this with a horse
and the revenant many pointed out the
similarity but both cases is just like
an old survival technique Echo Base
this is rope - I found them repeat I've
found them after the red and gold
squadrons of the previous film this
squadron is labeled rogue later the
movie rogue one established the origin
of this squadron the rebels who went
rogue from Yavin for to infiltrate
Sierra for the Death Star plans
Luke recovers in a bacta healing tank
and then gets a big wet one from his
sister guess we did it general Rican
alerts them to the probe droid ordering
the number is 1-1 3-8 in that order it's
another nod to George Lucas's previous
film th X 1-1 3-8
moving on to the Imperial fleet scored
to the famous Imperial March which John
Williams added to his Star Wars suite
starting with this film he took
inspiration from Gustav Holst's the
planets Mars bringer of war
[Music]
the scale of this fleet is conveyed
cleverly with the use of shadows that
bleed down the surface of the Star
Destroyer which already seems massive to
us based on how it entered the frame
with all the Thai fighters buzzing
around it but now this huge thing is
being engulfed in the shadow of
something even huger Vader's new Star
Destroyer in this film the executor and
finally looming largest over all these
things Vader's helmet itself now in
rogue one Gareth Edwards would similarly
use bleeding shadows to suggest the
scale of an impossibly large object in
that case it was a Star Destroyer
compared to the immense Death Star the
Empire invades Hoth with all-terrain
armoured transports ATT 80s or at-ats a
spokesman for George Lucas at one point
indicated the correct version is at-at
but to a lot of fans like I said it was
kind of a gift versus Gipp thing to
point if enough people say something
some way that's kind of how languages
get formed folks Lucas Films Dave Filoni
confirmed that there is no one way to
pronounce anything here that only a Sith
deals in absolutes I say you can say a
DAT you can say 8080 and you can say
Walker I'm for all three that's canon
because in the show
I have Imperials say walkers I have them
say at and I have them say 80 80 the 80
80s ads were inspired by the walking
tripods of HTT wells War of the Worlds
and her legs were based on the gantry
cranes and shipping ports for their
movements stop-motion animators studied
the walking patterns of elephants and
presumably also study when elephants
fall down Luke's gunner is named dak
named after film editor Dwayne Dunham's
dog dak but spelled differently and
Denis Lawson returns as wedge antilles
who wasn't originally scripted to appear
but in a fan interest led to Lucas
including him wasun actually returns
again to the series as wedge in episode
9 the rise of Skywalker so they bring
down one of the walkers with tow cables
a tactic that Peter Parker would later
suggest to bring down the giant Scott
Lang and Captain America Civil War hey
guys
Cultus no planning a walking things yeah
like a kid who heads at Lobot figurine
wouldn't know the name Hoth or wouldn't
have an opinion about 80 80 's versus a
DAT anyway the rebels evacuate and Han
takes evasive maneuvers the special
effects team created a new model of the
falcon for this movie which allowed them
to manipulate it around for barrel rolls
and flips that it wasn't able to do in
the first film han takes it through an
asteroid field apparently some of these
asteroids are a potato and one of the
VFX people's shoes at one point a TIE
fighter explodes on an asteroid and you
can see the pilot flipping away into
space Vader blows off steam in his
meditation chamber which gives us a
super brief but fascinating glimpse at
his scarred head this shot inspired so
much mystery among the Star Wars fans
that a young Gareth Edwards would see
this a movie and then later when he made
rogue one would tease a similar glimpse
of the back of Vader's head Isis back
the tank water lowered this chamber is
said to be a hyperbaric chamber that
charges the interior air to greater than
one atmospheric pressure which would
allow Vader to remove helmet and breathe
normally however in the movie you can
see the Vader has an additional
breathing mask in that chamber with
Vader taking command of the Imperial
Navy we see how his leadership is
actually pretty stubborn and reckless he
forced chokes like everyone and he leads
the Star Destroyers through the asteroid
field despite it tearing up most of
their ships actually love how one of the
captains as the ala chats with them kid
says bridge destroyed in the middle of
the conference Vader only moves out of
the field to get a signal to talk to his
boss the Emperor this being the first
glimpse we get of him there is a great
disturbance
fools actually this is the later edition
in which George Lucas added the in
McDiarmid as the Emperor probably around
the time he was shooting Revenge of the
Sith originally the emperor was played
by the hooded actress Marjorie eaten
with superimposed chimpanzee eyes over
her face and voiced by the actor Clive
Revell there was a great disturbance in
the force when the scene was changed the
dialogue was also expanded so that the
emperor describes Luke as the rebel that
destroyed the Death Star and Darth Vader
questions the possibility of Luke being
the offspring of Anakin Skywalker it
ends up being kind of redundant
self-contradictory to earlier in the
film but they just really want to
underline all of this boba fett also
makes his debut here even though he was
added to another special edition scene
in 97 originally this is the first time
we see him he wears the distinctive
armor of the people of Mandalore which
has shown up throughout the films and TV
series and you'll notice that he has a
string of hair around his armor that is
a Wookiee scalps that he wears as a
trophy which later gives Chewbacca yet
another reason to hate this guy
originally Boba Fett was voiced by actor
jason wingreen but Lucas dubbed over all
of his dialogue with prequel Jango Fett
actor Tamar Morrison who is now the
voice of Boba Fett and all the clone
troopers and pretty much everything
Lucasfilm does despite vova FETs letdown
demise and return the Jedi Empire
established his reputation as an immoral
badass man of few words never reveals
his face Lucas described him as the man
with no name from the Sergio Leone
westerns the other bounty hunters who
show up include Bosque ig-88 and the one
white is Dan gar who was once a fierce
rival of Han Solo's but was badly beaten
and now once revenge Luke in our to head
to the swamp planet of Dagobah or two
nearly gets swallowed by a swamp
creature wasn't given a name at the time
until a 93 video game that called it a
hey go bad an anagram of Dagobah when
Yoda appears Luke in the audience first
to see him as a comical nuisance as a
student of Joseph Campbell's hero's
journey George Lucas mentioned Yoda came
from the odd little side characters that
the hero ends up running into along the
path kind of like the Munchkins of The
Wizard of Oz but the name Yoda was based
on the Sanskrit term Yoda translating to
warrior suggesting his humble might he
speaks in inverted sentences objects
subject-verb order a structure used by
very few languages in our world with the
exception of a few based on the Amazon
River Basin in Empire returned the Jedi
in the Phantom Menace Yoda was voiced in
puppeted by Frank Oz in a team of
puppeteers
the whole set in this movie raised five
feet so that they could operate him from
underneath makeup artist stuart freeborn
based his design for Yoda space on his
own face combined with Albert Einstein's
to imbue the character with an inherent
wisdom of all the characters in the Star
Wars universe
Yoda is one of the few whose species in
origin has been deliberately left in
mystery when every extra in these movies
has a name and an action figure that
tells you something about his sacred
status we know only that they age very
slowly Yoda is nearly 900 years old here
and at one point a female of his race
yeah dolls at all the Jedi Council and
if you're up to date on more current
Star Wars stuff without spoiling
anything it sounds like we might start
to learn more about him now of course
Yodas annoying behavior is really just
an act designed to test Luke's patience
just to see how quickly is to anger the
boy has no patience
Yodas philosophy was inspired by
stoicism a Greek school of thought that
preached emotional control and that
virtue is based on knowledge I'm not
afraid you Yodas words foreshadowed the
darkness to come and reflect a
skepticism of Luke's bravery but really
the line underscores Empire's purpose as
a film to take a franchise about bravery
and brash heroism and burden it with
emotional stakes so that we now have a
reason to fear the darkness this fear
manifests later when Yoda sends Luke
into the cave what's in there again some
wise insight from the master the face of
darkness the real source of fear is our
own insecurities in Luke's case it's
Darth Vader but underneath that mask is
Luke's own face foreshadowing his
connection with Vader and Luke's inner
fear of being tempted to the dark side
and the three films of this original
trilogy Luke's wardrobe grows
increasingly darker film to film wipe in
a new hope gray an empire in black and
Return of the Jedi indicating his
journey deeper and deeper into the
depths of the dark side to confront his
father and bring him back from those
depths but before I continue thank you
to Zefat for sponsoring this episode
Black Friday's right around the corner
but don't you wish every day was Black
Friday so he was sure his way to buy
what you need at an affordable price
without the Lions a hassle in the stress
of a credit card interest with Zeb
atheras unzip it you can shop millions
of products from your favorite brands
and pay for them over time without any
interest simply choose the product you
love and pay a small portion of the
price to check out
you pay overtime at 0% interest I was
looking to buy a new sound bar system so
that I can hear all the will hum screams
is Irie watch the Star Wars movies CeBIT
had one perfect for me super easy to
find and recommend to my family to get
this for me for Christmas in addition to
interest-free credit as if it has no
cost to join no late fees and no
membership fees get a head start on your
holiday shopping with an unbeatable
selection of name-brand products and
competitive prices available for a low
upfront payment at 0% interest every day
feels like Black Friday was in it visit
zip it calm / new rockstars and get up
to $2,500 of interest-free credit in
onward with the breakdown unable to
balance his competing desires to
continue his Jedi training and maintain
his connection to his friends Luke
ignores the warnings of Yoda and the
ghost of obi-wan and leaves that line
was a real cryptic tease at the time
left over from lead brackets early
drafted the screenplay which actually
would have included the ghosts of Luke's
father Anakin revealing that Luke had a
sister named Nellis Skywalker but in
Lucas's and Kasdan's revision Anakin's
ghost was replaced with Yoda and the
ghost of obi-wan and it was in this
draft when Vader was revealed to be
Luke's father and returned the jedi
lucas answered that mystery a revealing
Leia as Luke's sister Wow Luke is on
Dagobah ha and Leia chewy and Threepio
hide in an asteroid unknowingly in the
bowels of an EXO course space slug his
moment when Threepio communes with the
Falcons computer this line would later
go on to inspire a subplot in solo in
which the Falcons computer came from
Landau's droid LV 37 which got damaged
in a shootout on Kessel
so they interfaced her with the Falcon
giving the ship it's the unique
navigation system that allowed it to run
the Kessel run in less than 12 parsecs
Han and Leia's flirty bit green finally
boils over fraid your terms
not jamming
[Music]
there's steamy though this may be the
passion between Han and Leia
it's just that passion on his cornering
her and a real dirty part of the Falcon
he's spitting game about being a
scoundrel
really the only thing classing up this
moment is John Williams famous love
theme I don't believe that Lucas has
dinner Kershner ever intended on Han and
Leia's love lasting but their time
together served a greater purpose than
their own happiness to inspire the
rebellion and later to inspire the
resistance after escaping the Minox in
the eggs of worth and fooling the
Imperial officers by hiding the Falcon
on a Star Destroyer they make their way
to Cloud City on Bespin where they are
greeted by Lando Calrissian Billy Dee
Williams had previously auditioned for
the role of Han Solo when Lucas had
conceived of the role as a black man
Landers right-hand man is lo box who
actually is a very interesting backstory
in Star Wars lore having joined Lando on
a job to take what ended up being the
Emperor's personal yacht leading robot
to having to sacrifice his personality
via his implant and after the events
have returned the Jedi Lando and Lobot
fight to liberate Cloud City Cloud City
was originally a scrapped concept from
the original Star Wars where it would
have hovered over the remnants of
Alderaan and served as a setting for Obi
Wan's duel with Vader the whole concept
was moved to Empire and for the special
edition Lucas actually refinished most
of the city exteriors that we c-3po gets
attacked and broken up into parts Chewie
finds him heading into a scrap furnace
run by a bunch of Ignatz beside the
furnace is an IG 86 sentinels Roy it's
similar to the model that ig-88 is and
IG 11 from the Mandalorian there's also
an igniter during the Mandalorian they
realized that Lando has sold them ounce
tube a dearth Vader tortures Han and he
hands him off to Boba Fett's
to be returned to Jabba the Hutt's
leading to Han being frozen in carbonite
[Music]
I love you
no in the original script Han was
supposed to say just remember that Leia
because I'll be back but reportedly it
wasn't clear Harrison Ford was going to
return for a third film so Kirchner had
Ford ad-lib a line final words old is
also a way truer response from a
scoundrel like Han again it's not a
romance built to last so instead of
reciprocating Han it takes the
opportunity to win their feud from
earlier when Luke arrives the Imperial
escort who uses leh as a human shield is
actually Jeremy Bulloch the actor who
physically played Boba Fett they
struggle to escape and another example
of how Empire is way darker than the
other two of the original trilogy both
of those ended military victory this one
they escaped by the skin of their teeth
and the final dramatic confrontation is
also super intimate and personal it's
just a duel between Luke and Vader
echoing the duel between Vader and
obi-wan which arrived at the midpoint of
that movie note the two dominant colors
here red and blue red platform against
the blue background reflecting Vader's
red lightsaber against Luke's blue
lightsaber on the whole empire is a very
blue movie with all the scenes on Hoth
Dagobah hitted in moody blue overtones
the arrival of so much red here reflects
the way Vader's hell fire has burnt its
way into Luke's world earlier on Dagobah
Luke felt a momentary deja vu and a
chill in the cave he confronted Vader in
a tunnel with sloped archways which are
natural doppelgangers of the mechanical
trap he now finds himself in the real
Vader while Luke defeated Vader easily
in the cave Yoda describe that moment as
a failure that's because the darkside
tricked Luke into thinking he could take
Vader and now Luke is completely
outmatched against a far more
experienced Force practitioner
whereas Luke struggled to lift a few
stones Vader now mirages them with crate
after crate
whereas luke clutches to his lightsaber
for dear life with both hands Vader
confidently strikes against his old
blade with just one hand
it's not until the duel ends that Vader
stops playing around he severs Luke's
hand and hits him with the truth
never told you what happened they will
father he told me enough he killed you
[Music]
now Bader is actually similar to the
German bata which means father and we
know the Empire is space Nazis so there
you go this reveal was so kept under
secrecy that Mark Hamill was only told
shortly before shooting the scene and
David Prowse the actor physically played
Vader was actually told to say the line
obi-wan killed your father nowadays this
kind of twist provokes scepticism but in
the days of empire this twist worked a
because it hadn't been done so many
times and be because it turns the
villain from a masked stranger into well
still a masked stranger but one whose
blood runs through our veins who knows
us in a way that we don't know ourselves
it's terrifying it's like discovering a
murderer who broke into your house you
Steve sleep in your bedroom you're just
wondering did you know that before you
got in what's in this for you you psycho
I sadly grew up knowing the truth about
Darth Vader before seeing any Star Wars
film oh what an egg who'da thought Darth
Vader was Luke Skywalker's father and I
think many in our generation have
forgotten that sensation of shock and
disgust and pathos that this revelation
brings it's actually kind of amazing to
see YouTube videos of parents showing
their kids Empire for the first time
[Music]
yeah that is the feeling in which this
moment should live on for each of us
because despite the grace notes that
close out Empire Luke getting rescued
Luke and Leia gazing out of the galaxy
Empire leaves us with a nagging unease
that this world is dark hiding truths
about ourselves that we are not ready to
hear one of the final shots of Luke
shows him receiving a new mechanical
hand like his father shown in act 1 and
a glimpse of scarred flesh fused with
machine
Luke is one step closer in a similar
transformation to an Augmented amputee
just like his Potter a Skywalker scarred
and scared be sure to check out my
analysis of the first Star Wars and keep
an eye out for my breakdown of Return of
the Jedi we're gonna keep this train
going comment down below with what you
love about this film follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at ei vas and
follow new rock stars and subscribe to
this channel on YouTube and subscribe to
our WikiLeaks podcast speed for early
audio versions of this stuff thank you
for joining me and I'm just always
wondering what was Luke gonna say to Han
[Music]